i love this look by the way this is
you can pull that off i don't think i
could pull that off are you sure i mean
i
i don't know i think uh you know it's
it's interesting when you're this tall
and you're bulb and you have a big
goatee people treat you differently
people are oh they're afraid of you
right yeah
they're afraid the baldness and the
devil the devil goatee
you got all that going for you uh you
look like someone who just emerged from
hell
and is here for vengeance i wonder if we
could we could actually do that right
now
like kind of you know
[Laughter]
conan
you you know i want to ask you about
this because you just brought it to mind
i know that you are
speaking about other worlds netherworlds
you're a big dungeons and dragons guy
i mean you take this very seriously and
you
run a d and d game that a lot of
celebrities like
a-list celebrities are in your dnd game
is that correct
this is correct yes that is correct
what is your yeah it's a lot of fun you
know uh all of us used to play when we
were younger
um it was instrumental for a lot of us
uh in terms of what we wanted doing for
a career you know for me as an
actor uh you know character building
writing backstories i was doing this
stuff before i
even started acting or even understood
that that was something you could do for
a profession
and you know certainly that the guys who
created game of thrones
play in my group certainly that was that
was instrumental for them
in creating long-form storytelling
within a fantasy world i mean
with dragons and you know archetypical
warriors and fighters and and wizards
and things like that
um but also you you might not know that
like my trainer
of the past 10 years who is a crossfit
champion was also huge into dundas and
dragons the big show
seven foot four i know a big show
he's been on my show countless times i
love that guy he's talking about a big
big show is in my dnd group and would
charter flights from florida
to come in on friday to play and and
also
vince vaughn is in your group vince
vaughn is in my group
tom morello guitar god tom morello uh
all
super like hardcore serious
uh when when we were younger about uh d
d and i got the idea to to start playing
again
and it's become this thing that like all
of us kind of live for
during the week to get to friday to play
this game and see each other and you
know
talk smack and roll dice and yell at
each other and and uh
it's so much fun and you are a dungeon
master i'm told which means
you hold a great deal of power and
knowledge as dungeon master in the d d
world correct
yes yes um yes uh yes yes conan
um yeah no i i so i'm kind of the i'm
like a show runner
of our show where you know say dan
and dave for game of thrones were
responsible for coming up with the
storyline
and and where the plot was going to go
and then who all the characters are
they're going to step in and interact
with the main characters
i'm that person so i also do all of the
voices for all of those characters oh
you do the voices too
i do voices yeah so anytime they meet a
new character
uh i i do the voice of that character if
they go to a store or a blacksmith's
shop or you know an an alchemist shop
um you know they might find who you know
um high instead what can i get you in
you know and it's like these two people
from pittsburgh he's like talking to him
about like
you know their blacksmith needs you know
against need a great sword in that yeah
we can we can uh we can knock one of
them out for you come on back though
tomorrow morning
i love that these guys that run this
magical shop are from pittsburgh
yeah so they keep going back to the shop
to make me do the voice or
for example there was a seagull there's
a there's like a character in the
in the group who can speak to animals so
he thinks it's really funny to make me
do voices for all these different
animals so he always wants to talk to
every animal he can find
you know is there a you know oh i want
to talk to the seagull
you know the seagull is really
unimpressed with everything they've done
you know i thought you'd be dead by now
this is crazy
and you know chris what's your name
chris walken is the seagull
his name is christopher squawkin
and so he'll fly around and meet them or
you know hey i want to talk to that
squirrel and see if the squirrel saw
anyone run through the forest and it's
like
okay here we go now oh hi what's going
on guys that's crazy
yeah i saw a couple people run by here
earlier and you know you're
now you're the satanic christmas animals
from south park
so where would um let's say i was in
this game
you know let's pretend i'm an a-lister
and i'm in this game
uh what animal would i be what what
would you see me
being do you see i mean you're the show
runner you're the
dungeon master what would i do what
would i be
uh like animal-wise or character-wise
because
you could let me ask you a question like
you know would you would you rather
fight with a sword and be kind of some
kind of you know conan the barbarian s
character or are you more like a wizard
or someone who casts spells
yeah i don't want to personally be in
any danger so i like the idea of being
far away from the actual fighting and
maybe uh
i'm doing incantations or maybe just
making threatening phone calls
but i'm not someone who's actually in
the nothing i don't have a sword or a
weapon i can't get hurt
i like the threatening phone call idea
because there's spells where you could
like
speak into someone's brain so you could
just send
evil messages into people's brain from
way in the back that's what i do
here at the late night show with people
that work with me
you know is for years i just writers
anyone who works on the show i'm
constantly
i'm playing with their minds uh i'm
passive-aggressive
you know that that's my i think that's
my talent
yelling at andy maybe i don't know
that's right people don't know this but
when we started the
interview just before as we were about
to start and we were ready to go
andy was right back here talking as loud
as humanly possible
and you were on the line and i was like
andy and they suck
and he started yelling back at me and
you were loving it you were enjoying
well it was like when you're when you're
a kid and you're on the phone with your
friend
and mom leave me alone you know they
start screaming at their mom
it was like one of those where you got
to see our real
andy are you back there did he take off
where does he go
he's out in the alley like smoking weed
it's unbelievable
it's incredible this is such an
unprofessional organization he was back
there yelling and making noise
but i think he did leave i think he's in
the alley outside the theater
40 chance he's high right is that right
yeah what's a gateway drug that the the
you know smoking the weed i mean next
thing you know
andy's on heroin meth something yeah and
then
next thing you know he's playing
dungeons and dragons so i mean
he got to be careful that's how it works
uh i love this i love that now when you
play dungeons and dragons do you guys
trash talk
each other is that a game where you can
trash talk like let's say you and vince
vaughn do you guys get into it
yeah in fact vince's character
was attempting to buy a magic carpet
so in the game there's like a there was
a shop you know what kind of getchance
and then he came in and uh you know like
a magic carpet and all of a sudden he
got into this
it was like a used car battle you know
where he was trying to work me down
over this used magic carpet and i was
this used magic carpet salesman that was
like you know trying to sell vince on
the fact that he needs the bigger model
he needs to spend a little more money
and he's trying to work me down the road
it went on for five to ten minutes this
improv between vince's character and my
used magic carpet salesman and everyone
in the room was screaming and laughing
and on the ground
crying my question is where's sophia
when all this is happening
you're married to one of the most
beautiful women in the world
one of the sexiest women to have ever
lived and you're in a room
playing dungeons and dragons where is
she
does she approve of all of this
well here's the thing coded she knows
where i am
i'm i'm not out in a back alley getting
in trouble
yeah okay all right right so she always
knows it every time where you are and
what you're up to
she knows where i am yeah and i think
that's the most important thing